[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
- What happened was,
he was on the plane,
and he was served lunch,
and on the plate was
some broccoli.
He sees the plate in front
of him, he sits back,
he looks at the steward,
and he says, "You know,
"I've hated broccoli ever
since I was a little boy.
"My mother made me
eat broccoli.
"And now that I'm President
of the United States,
"I'm not gonna eat broccoli
anymore.
"I don't want to see it,
I don't want to smell it,
"I don't want it around me.
It's gone from this plane."
So they banned broccoli
from Air Force One.
- One day, we were an hour out
and the president's doctor
came up to me
extremely seriously and said,
"Howie, was there broccoli
in that lasagna for lunch?"
And I said, "Yes, sir,
there was."
And he said, "Well, you know,
the President's allergic
to broccoli."
♪ ♪
That really hit me.
I am supposed
to know that stuff.
And I go downstairs,
and the doctor
is now getting a shot
out of his bag to give
to the President.
And I said, "How is he doing?"
He said, "He's not doing well."
Two Secret Service gentlemen
are holding the President up
on each side, and he's
kind of staggering
out to go down the steps.
Now, this--
I'm feeling terrible.
My pager went off,
and my deputy said,
"Chief, the pilot
needs to see you
in the pilot's office."
You're walking into
the office,
and the whole crew was
in the office,
and I'm panicking.
And I looked over,
and Colonel Jackson,
our navigator--fine fella--
uh, I think he knew
I was really high-strung,
and he gave me the thumbs-up
with a smile.
And I said, "Oh, you guys
are messing with me."
They were all in on it,
the entire crew
and the President and his
staff and the doctor.
They were all in
on the prank.